we have breaking news out of North
Carolina overnight where law enforcement
captured three out of four escaped
inmates from Ohio the men were taken
into custody and carry in the Raleigh
area they escaped from the Galea County
Jail that's in the southern part of Ohio
early yesterday morning one inmate is
still at large at this hour Tom Hanson
is at gallipoli so hyoe at the jail
where they were held so tom how'd they
get away good morning Anthony while the
inmates escaped Galia county jail behind
me here in ohio around 12 a.m. Sunday
using a shank to overpower two female
corrections officers according to
authorities the men then took down a
secure door to the outside and stole a
corrections vehicle to make the getaway
authorities are asking people in the
town of Cary to be on the lookout for
Lawrence Lee who is still on the run the
other three men Brian Martin Christopher
Clemente and Troy McDaniel were found at
a Red Roof Inn and carry around 2:00
a.m. all three people were taken into
custody peacefully this is the second
time in a month that Brian Martin
escaped the jail which has been recently
criticized for having multiple jail
breaks now the jail did not have any
male corrections officers working the
night of the escape and three of the
four fugitives who were apprehended were
taken to a local County Public Safety
Center where they await extradition back
here to Ohio Tony
Tom Hanson reporting Tom thank you very
much